[музика]
Щиро вітаємо вас Ми раді що ви дивитесь
на вашу програму У фокусі і робить
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle у Великій
Британії новий Король і він із
громадським співчуттям ховає свою матір
королева Єлизавета другу
на цій церемонії з кролевою прощається
він і вся країна водночас громадська
увага зараз повністю прикута до нового
монарха
Чарльз третій робить ці складні кроки І
приймає важку спадщину
Але чи потрібен зараз країні Монарх це
питання цікавить не лише багатьох
британців але країни що належать до
співдружності нації решти Британської
імперії Яка ще 100 років тому була
світовою державою
Чарльз є королем у 15 із 56 країн
союздержав підтримують традицію Але чи є
в неї майбутнє вже зараз через третій
вимушений остерігатися відцентрованих
сил
кадри з кращих часів у 2018 році
королева зустрічається у віндзорському
замку з главами держав і урядів
британської співдружності також присутні
тодішній Принц і сьогоднішній король
Чарльз 3 для королеви клуб держав був
важливим партнером
для мене залишається великою радістю та
честю служити вам у ролі голови
співдружності
а також із гордістю та задоволенням
відзначити що це процвітаюча мережа я
щиро бажаю щоб співдружність пропонувала
стабільність і спадкоємність також і
майбутнім поколінням
королева стала символічною главою
співдружності та чи зможе взяти на себе
цю роль також і її син це невідомо
позаяк деякі з 15 основних держав
колишніх колоній йде Чарльз офіційно є
королем більше не хочуть монархії
як і однозначно керівна роль Великої
Британії у співдружності не викарбувано
на камені
новий король уже підготувався до цього
Кажуть спостерігачі зокрема Девід хавал
багаторічний дослідник співдружності
король чарль займається цим упродовж
багатьох років він знає більшість країн
світу звичайно ті що входять до
співдружності
він знає принаймні так само добре як і
більшість політиків де нам потрібно
налагодити нові зв'язки та мережі
мережі та рівні права але не під
керівництвом британської корони
чарльзові вже довелося відчути на собі
наслідки цієї думки у листопаді 2021
року
Барбадос вирішив стати Республікою
тодішній принц виглядав під час
церемонії як актор другого плану
заснування республіки стане для нас
новим початком
із 16 держав які ми керували британська
корона їх стало 15 і вітер дме все
різкіше
[оплески]
син Чарльза Вільям відвідав навесні 2022
року Багамські острови беліста Ямайку
у всіх трьох країнах номінальною главою
держави є зараз його батько але всі три
держави хочуть це змінити
замість сердець від населення принц
Вільям отримав критику У фокусі Рабство
у британський колоніальний час
президент Ямайки перед увімкненими
камерами оголосив вільяму про прощання з
монархією
Ми йдемо далі
[музика]
і маємо намір уже незабаром досягти
наших цілей розвитку та реалізувати наші
справжні амбіції а також долю незалежної
розвиненої та процвітаючої країни
деяким критикам на ямайці недостатньо
навіть цієї Незалежності Вони вимагають
компенсації за страждання під
колоніальною владою
наші сьогоднішні економічні умови є
наслідком колоніалізму
Наслідком цього є наші психологічні
проблеми наш брак розвитку також є
прямим наслідком колоніальної ери
майбутні британської корони обговорюють
також і в Австралії Другий за величиною
країні співдружності але молодь
підтримує збереження Чарльза номінальним
королем Австралії
опитування показує що моє покоління є
найбільш про монаргічним
Республіка хочуть передусім Бебі бумери
Я знаю багатьох лівий налаштованих людей
які не є монархістами але підтримують що
систему тому що не бачить кращої
альтернативи
Але чи може Чарльз бути символом нової
співдружності адже Провідна роль Великої
Британії хоча історичної обумовлена але
більше не є актуальною каже дослідник
співдружності хавел
життя змінюється
дипломати повинні пристосовуватися вони
повинні зрозуміти що часи центрального
офісу та багатьох сателітів минулих
співдружність - це мережа партнерів тут
не править британська корона мова йде
про Світову дружбу сильні допомагають
слабким
на останньому саміті співдружності
кілька місяців тому тодішній принц
Чарльз також говорив про британську
колоніальну еру страждання багатьох
людей і помилки однак вибачення із його
вуст не прозвучало
Чарльз третій повинен знайти Нову роль
для королівського дому в ролі блідої
копії вічної королеви Він мабуть
провалиться
у Чехії на вулиці виходить все більше
людей Вони протестують проти
енергетичної політики власного уряду
навряд чи ще якась країна в Європі
настільки залежить від російського газу
альтернативні постачальники енергії тут
відсутні що призводить до підвищення цін
і це помітно в чеському Горохові там
знаходиться мабуть найстаріший завод
склав в Європі він особливо потребує
дорогої енергії поза Як без високих
температур печі складу увів працювати не
можуть перед операторами постала дилема
звичайно вона ще є ідилія виспалінових
горах гарахов місто на чесько-польському
кордоні всесвітньо відоме особливо для
любителів зимових видів спорту
а от символ чеських стрибунів на лижах
трамплін у Харкові він нагадує руїну і
через кілька метрів вже наступна купа
уламків
щоб Горіли ці печі оператор франтішик
новусад щодня повинен платити у
перерахунку у 4500 євро
рік тому це було 400 євро
не треба вміти рахувати каже Новосад щоб
зрозуміти що це зовсім не вигідно я
оптиміст ми виживаємо тому що витрачаємо
свої резерви ми їх відкладали наприклад
на нову половину піч 400 тисяч євро ці
гроші ми витратили ще в першому півріччі
і тепер ми вже починаємо використовувати
інші заощадження а щодо наших
працівників ми не тільки не можемо
підвищити їм зарплати Ми вимушені навіть
скоротити їхній премії щоб у нас були
гроші на оплату енергії А як сприймають
робітники зменшення свого доходу
через інфляцію у Чехію понад 16% та
збільшення витрат їх не треба і питати
Вони раді що в нинішній ситуації в
країні взагалі ще є робота у Чехії також
вимагають економити газ на підприємствах
але на такому підприємстві каже Новосад
економити неможливо або піч працює або
ні
адже людям байдуже Звідки надходить газ
їм потрібна безпечна енергія особливо
перед зимою чи поступає вона з Америки
чи з Росії чи з Китаю їм все одно вони
хочуть отримати енергію за доступними
цінами навіть іщеською зарплатою
Прага 4 вересня 2022 року
70 тисяч людей за оцінками поліції
протестували тут проти різкого
підвищення цін на енергоносії і вимагали
відставки уряду
багато хто які Новосад боїться
невпевненості у майбутньому
але організатори демонстрація також
частина натовпу стоять на боці Росії
вимагаючи виходу із НАТО та ЄС
розчаровані та ще й екстремісти занадто
вибухонебезпечний союз
на демонстрації виступив також декан
економічного університету його політична
орієнтація є доволі спірною але він
чітко вимагає припинити економічну
блокаду
коли ми накладаємо санкції які діють
тоді Гаразд але коли ми вже через кілька
місяців бачимо що санкції проти Росії
лише зміцнюють російську економіку це
вже справжня проблема
чи справді санкції такі безглузді
як сильно розпадається єдність у Чехії
раз два три наверх Давай раз два три
південноамериканські звуки у
чесько-українському центрі для зустрічей
Тут збираються жінки щоб танцюючи забути
про дискусії навколо війни в Україні
центром для зустрічей керує Ольга
черепюк
сама Вона вже розмовляє Чеською хоча
втекла з України Наприкінці лютого
відтоді настрій у Чехії змінився
зима не за горами і звичайно кожен
хвилюється за свій гаманець
Але я вважаю що у глибині душі більшість
Чехів за підтримку України і за те що ця
війна повинна закінчитися якомога швидше
за кількістю населення Чехія прийняла
найбільше біженців з України Діти тут
які потрібно ходять до шкіл та дитсадків
і багато жінок які Ольга черепюк знайшли
тут роботу Вона може зрозуміти страхи
своїх нових сусідів через високі ціни на
енергоносії але в неї також є чітка
відповідь
я не думаю що ми можемо платити за газ
людськими живцями і кров'ю чехи ще добре
пам'ятають 1968 рік і російсько-окупацію
що в нас коїться і як почуваються люди в
Україні
багато Чехів розуміють цю позицію але
хочуть щоб зрозуміли і їхні проблеми
схвалення допомоги Україні В країні є
майже непорушним натомість розпадається
схвалення уряду
назад до складуїв без полінових горах
франтішик новусад також не хоче щоб
демонстрацію у Празі сприймали як
демонстрацію проти України тут її
підтримують
Однак не всі в змозі заплатити за газ і
тоді він буде вимушений відключити своїй
печі але відключення каже він війну не
закінчить
Вона втекла з Ірану від утиски і
безперспективності для жінок таких як
Соня але хебанд ситуація там є важкою
зараз запроваджу жінок в Україні на
вулицях виходять тисячі людей
в Німеччині Sony бракує для повного
щастя лише роботи
водночас багато німецьких підприємств
зараз відчайдушно шукають кваліфікований
персонал без програшна ситуація для Sony
та Deutsche Band
компанія отримає високомотивовану
співробітницю а біженка реалізовує своє
бажання вона стане машиністкою
бо є мрія колись керувати цим швидкісним
потягом Ice
депо приміської залізниці біля Штутгарта
моторний вагон 43070 набирає швидкість
майже 70 метрів завдовжки 3 200 кінських
сил у кабіні водія Соня аллагибанд яка
Майже 6 років тому втекла із рану до
Німеччини
Я навіть не думала що зможу тут робити
щось подібне
але зараз стало краще
я більше не нервую менше переживаю
і радію що скоро зможу їхати самостійно
навчання є пілотним проектом наразі 14
біженців перекваліфіковуються на
Машиністів які Соня Вони походять із
рану а також із Сирії та Афганістану
Подивись коли ти натиснеш сюди і прийдеш
на інформацію то побачиш Чого ще бракує
Бачиш він ще не набрав 8 бар
новий виклик також і для інструктора
Алекса хелма
я сподівався що ці люди розмовляють
німецькою і вони вмотивовані більше я ні
про що не думав я просто дозволив собі
взятись за цю справу і я справді приємно
здивований ми робимо все можливе під час
навчання але зрештою результат залежить
від них
Соня жінка на локомотиві у Німеччині це
давно стало звичним але для жінки це
величезний крок до рівних можливостей
немає жінок-машиністов жінкам заборонено
виконувати цю роботу
які багато чого іншого З чим вона не
погоджувалася на своїй батьківщині але
вона не хоче про це говорити через страх
перед режимом
жінка залишила свою роботу вчительки
англійської мови і обхідними шляхами
втекла до Німеччини
сама тільки зчікою своєю собакою
її сім'я живе в Ірані і пишається
кар'єрою Соні на Deutsche Band
всі радіють
коли в мене іспити чи заліки я пишу
батькові і він каже Так ти з усім
впораєшся ти все зможеш
клас біженців Соні 13 чоловіків і вона
єдина жінка
контактна планка струму приймача завжди
повинна залишатися у горизонтальному
положенні адже на шляху може бути міст і
тоді струмоприймач має бути опущеним
сьогодні Андреас шенбергер пояснює
струмоприймач для біженців це
безсумнівно нова інформація далі вони
повинні дістати зошити і заповнити
операційну карту усі тут мали раніше
інші професії з 2016 року коли до
Німеччини приїхало багато біженців
компанія Deutsche Band створила для них
понад 700 навчальних місць що також на
користь компанії які бракує
кваліфікованих працівників директор
відділу кадрів ради що більшість
біженців такі успішні
якщо я поодиноких випадках хтось не
доходить до іспиту бо ми бачимо що
рівень мотивації досить високий тому ми
пишаємося новими працівниками які потім
складаються іспит
і таким людям як Соня цього недостатньо
у неї вже є нові плани які йдуть
набагато далі якщо мені вдасться стати
машиністкою приміської залізниці то я
без сумніву зможу водити також і потяги
Айс
[оплески]
їхати зі швидкістю 300 кілометрів за
годину в Інтерсіті Експрес Це її нова
мрія після втечі зарано до Німеччини
Соня Алла хибанд хоче завжди рухатися
вперед
Зараз ми представимо вам Хусейна смайча
підприємцям мусульмани з Боснії та
Герцеговини мусульмани мають відбудовує
християнську церкву руїна якої знайшов
на своїй ділянці
насправді це незвично і є сенсацією
Боснії та герцеговині оскільки ця
південно-європейська країна глибоко
розділена та багато етнічна держава
розрізнені групи якою довго воювали між
собою
показати приклад будівництва церкви в
бугойно
його церква ще не закінчена але справи
вже далеко просунулася офіційно вони
освятили її на початку серпня тепер каже
Хусейн смайлич перерва наближається зима
і вони сподіваються на кілька пожертв
які допоможуть продовжити будівництво
навесні адже Ця церква справа його життя
я дуже щасливий і люди зрозуміють що Ця
церква є церквою миру любові та поваги
один до одного
вона об'єднує людей а не роз'єднує
мусульманин будує католицьку церкву щоб
примирити свою розділену країну
тому що рівно 30 років тому у Боснії
розпочалася війна Серби хорвати та
босніця влаштували між собою побоїще
загинули сотні тисяч людей війна
залишила глибокі рани
на багатьох будинках ще й досі є дірки
від куль які в душах людей що й досі
страждають від війни
він і його сім'я весь час були тут у
своєму рідному місті бугойно розповідає
гусейн
більше він нічого не каже
Я не говорю про цю війну
я не хочу про це говорити
для мене Це минуле і чесно кажучи я не
люблю про це згадувати
але це роблять інші
особливо Зараз перед виборами ціла Каста
політиків процвітає на тому що Боснія
все ще розділена позаяк це забезпечує
їхню владу лідер боснійських сербів
проводить військові поради
боснійські та хорватські політики
голосно сперечаються про право голосу
такого поганого настрою тут не було
давно
я справді здивований що між босніцями та
хорватами існує така напруга при тому що
завжди був компроміс і вони
співпрацювали А цього разу я не знаю
бажання мого життя є зміна ситуації в
нашій Боснії щоб нам усім було краще І
щоб наша Молодь не покидала країну
війна давно закінчилася але нічого не
змінилося
натомість ситуація лише загострюється
люди у Боснії каже Хусейн втомилися від
націоналістичних тунів своїх політиків
політики ми ж бачимо що вони роблять
Усі вони хочуть нас роз'єднати
розбурхати людей
мені це так набридло
тому що каже Хусейн насправді різні
релігії співіснують у Боснії упродовж
століть
підтвердженням є ці кам'яні докази
він виявив їх випадково коли хотів
будувати на своїй ділянці замість того
щоб залити фундамент він знайшов її
середньовічну церкву
Я не був розчарований коли ми виявили ці
стіни
адже вони були фундаментом
середньовічної церкви я знав що це скарб
під науковим керівництвом він
продовжував розкопки за власні кошти і
нарешті натрапив на маленьку сенсацію
могилу боснійської королеви Єлени
вона правила країною з 1395 по 1398 рік
як королева всіх босніців ігор
саговинців сербів і хорватів
на її честь він спорудив пам'ятник його
натхнення об'єднання всіх народів Боснії
тому він знову будує на цьому місці
церкву і підтримка надходить йому з
усієї країни Цю церкву будували ми всі
камінь за каменем усіх хто робив
пожертви навіть не перерахували їх Серби
мусульмани хорвати адже ми всі просто
люди нова церква називається церквою
Богоматері ангелів і попри Всі
націоналістичні відтінки виборчої
кампанії вона здатна стати новим
символом миру у Боснії через 30 років
після війни
у Давіда комета є професія він фермер і
цей його захоплення
паралельно Він працює шоубізнесі бо це
йому до душі
і те й іншим він робить своєму дворі щоб
матеріально виживати вранці Він має
годувати корів а ввечері робити шоу Чи
це дійсно так достатнім доказом є
численні гості які роками відвідують
його професійне сценічне шоу маленькому
селі Гарік
ми в сільській місцевості
тут відбувається щось Надзвичайне
[музика]
якраз починається
і за божевільною ідеєю стоїть дзвін
Давид Комер
Зал заповнений
у програмі професійне Кабаре з усім
антуражем
[музика]
А я
Коли стало зрозуміло що я хочу відкрити
Кабаре всі старші люди в селі приходили
до Мого діда і казали твій онуки де
хибним шляхом кабереться наркотики та
проститутки Ось така в них була думка
[музика]
вже
ці фен професійна музикантка і співає
тут 4 рази на тиждень
[музика]
публіка в захваті і здивована
те що все це відбувається тут у селі
дуже далеко від усього це справжні
божевілля
тут така дружня атмосфера ти в сільській
місцевості це чудово
Коли ти приїжджаєш сюди наприкінці дня
То бачиш пагорби та височини
а тут Ти зовсім в іншому світі але
наступного ранку світ Давіда виглядає
так
після короткої ночі він уже знову стоїть
о 7 годині ранку у стайні
Я почуваюся добре коли я з коровами
кабере моя робота але ось це моя
пристрасть дві роботи одночасно це
досить важко
мій бухгалтер каже мені Припини
займатись коровами і займайся Кабаре та
фермерським магазином тоді ти матимеш
вільні вихідні і зможеш поїхати у
відпустку але Суть не в цьому А в тому
чи хоче французька держава врятувати
такі Малі підприємства Як наше Я думаю
Їй більше до вподоби величезні ферми з
тисячою корів на 1000 гектарів але в
такому фермерстві Ми не хочемо брати
участь
рід свого батька Жанна Луї давіду
спаткував 100 корів і 700 курей
чи сподобалась батько ідея Кабаре Давида
він божевільний адже це не сільське
господарство Ми думали що він продовжить
нашу справу
а він виробляє ось таке лише одне
сільське господарство вже не приносить
сьогодні достатньо грошей
сьогодні занадто багато людей хочуть
отримувати надприбутки
скрізь влазять посередники Тому це
більше не вигідно
у Франції щодня закривається 27 ферм
[музика]
ідея Давіда з Кабаре спрацювала тим
часом він навіть зміг найняти на роботу
15 людей а в кабаре у хліву щовечора
Аншлаг
[музика]
Я впевнений що крім цього шоу слід
розширити
знаходимось Це була програма У фокусі
Європи телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
Дякуємо що залишалися з нами на все
добре до побачення
українською мовою звучало центром Меді
ініціативи переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та лесюн
Київ 2022 рік
[музика]